the Joe Rogan experience I just saw this
yes they don't know why it was coming
around but this is Bo Jackson throwing
somebody out flat-footed from the
outfield that's not the sorry it's not
this one but it's his next one bo
Jackson was every one of the freakiest
athletes of all time his arm is so crazy
where everything was crazy if he didn't
get hurt in that football game look at
this jumps off the wall so he avoids all
the impacts literally just ran up the
wall yeah Bobo knew everything
he's a very amazing football that was
just to sports play to sports but world
class at both sports it wasn't until the
football injury that he had to get hip
replacement and then one of those days
the first person you pick like I got
this [ __ ] what story and
everything anything and everything
there's certain dudes just have the
perfect build the perfect kinetics and
then work ethic another one is a Hershel
Walker the kershel Walker his knees are
destroyed now yeah they say he like he
can barely like he can barely walk now
he'll still [ __ ] you up
Hershel Walker was he was [ __ ] people
up in Strikeforce when he was in his
late 40s I was thinking Earl Campbell
I don't think Hershel Walker has bad
knees he was fighting almost until he
was 50 he was fighting in Strikeforce oh
oh yeah oh yeah Hershel Walker at 48 49
whatever he wasn't he was fighting
looked like a 30 year old perfect
specimen of an athlete he didn't look
like an older athlete like doing
something different I trying to bite it
looks like he's [ __ ] world-class
ripped full six-pack super jacked at 40
what's what is his age there what is it
for you
48 look that right there 40 yes dude
look at the build on this [ __ ] guy
and he destroyed the student Strikeforce
he beat a few guys he was undefeated in
MMA and the way he would beat these guys
was just first of all he had a long
martial arts background like you've done
martial arts before I didn't I've never
known any of this but he's got such a
crazy disciplined work ethic that like
his body is still in pristine
shape in his late 40s now I don't know
if he's taking hormones or anything here
but either way the way this guy looked
in his 40s in a way I mean just like his
face his face yeah that's crazy that guy
would do push-ups and sit-ups and
bodyweight squats and and and [ __ ] over
weightlifting that was like his big
thing was that he did mostly
calisthenics I had no idea that he ever
did dude Herschel Walker was that's the
thing when when he started fighting
people were like oh you know he's like a
guy who still wants to compete who used
to be world-class at something he
probably won't be good at fighting right
he's [ __ ] look like it was just like
a show no he looks like a professional
mixed martial arts fighter I wouldn't
say he looked like the best in the world
but he was professional and he even went
to one of the best gyms in the world he
went to aka aka is in San Jose it's one
of the best mixed martial arts Cain
Velasquez Daniel Cormier John Fitch Josh
Koscheck mean go down the list lobby
train was on the top Peters came out of
there yeah it's a great gym and they
have been training world-class fighters
forever so he went to the Lions Den he
would nurmagomedov train who would Mike
Swick trained there I mean it's the it
was the common store he went to
commissary he went to comedy right in
there and he trade there look at that
look at that come on man who the [ __ ]
looks like that in the late 40s and does
professional cage fighting after a long
career I felt special man he was no idea
oh my god dude and I'm telling you every
fight was like this
[Applause]